healthcare
is all about
behavioral change
just because you develop diabetes
doesn't mean you have to die with it
right and
right so
diet and exercise can go a long way
outside of taking the pill right so how
do you how do you
and it's hard
it trust me it's hard
my father was a diabetic i get it uh and
uh and if you don't have someone to
coach you outside of the doctor's office
it's very very tough
welcome to 20-minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lomitek and
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance opposed hillel at stanford
leap and birthright excel
welcome to 20 minute leaders today we
are in the health tech space meet tom
foley chief growth officer of genie md
tom has over 30 years of experience in
information technology he has led many
transformative initiatives in and out of
healthcare his strategic thinking and
innovative approaches span across the
wrists to cloud continuum to affect the
manner in which delivery of care is
imagined globally foley also moderated
the health innovation think tank an
executive collaborative made up of 50
healthcare delivery systems pay
organization and healthcare i.t vendor
thought leaders who offer their insights
leading to the establishment of best
practices on a variety of issues
associated with value-based care
connected health and virtual care
tom foley welcome to 20 minute leaders
thank you so much for joining me how are
you
awesome thank you very much for having
me thank you looking forward to the
conversation thank you very very much
for being here i'm excited to talk to
you about genie md or today the the
chief growth officer but you've been in
the tele telemedicine space for a while
and thinking about health tech and
and especially you know during corona uh
more than ever it's it's a
it's evident this is something that we
need and i'm excited to hear the
founding story of genie md but also
about the different struggles and the
different things that are happening
around the world that that you know they
made this a necessity and so tom maybe
to get started tell me a little bit
about your own career your own life and
then sort of the things that that guide
you in the decisions you make about what
things you do
happy to do so so you know my career
started long ago
uh
with ups actually uh so ups believe it
or not
uh in the
mid 80s
that's how long ago i uh my career
started but in the mid 80s when you
called ups to pick up a package they
hand wrote that information
and then they faxed it over to the
package car center as they called them
distribution centers and it got to the
vehicle that said go pick up this
package
i started out uh so in in 86 they
started automating ups
uh so my very first project was the lead
systems programmer on how to automate
the telephone call center so instead of
handwriting it put it in a computer so
we did some very innovative things in
the fall tolerance space uh using pcs
again think about use of pcs in 1985 86
versus what they do today um and uh and
then that led to
okay i got a i got a package
how do i
just like fedex you know at the time
fedex you know you the fedex truck drove
away and you knew that the package was
delivered uh so i got involved in
wireless data at ups and uh
and and then and then just then joined a
wireless data company actually we helped
build one of the first national wireless
data networks in the country i left ups
and went to a company called ram mobile
data and again think about it 1992
to 95
wireless data
what the heck is that right yeah so the
thing is about the cell phone
and what it was then you know again a
big brick you know
it was like a backpack you needed with
long antennas right it wasn't the iphone
that's for sure and it wasn't an android
device either uh but the point is that
uh we built out a one of the ram mobile
data built out one of the first national
wireless data networks
uh in the country uh it's now uh all
that frequency and things that nature
was uh uh sold off eventually it ends up
being in the hands of 18t wireless data
very very cool
yeah and then and then from there i got
involved in a number of innovative
scenarios and in the early 2000s i made
a specific jump to healthcare i was
doing my own independent consulting for
about seven years i read that i can
remember reading this article about how
all this paper
existed in health care
and um and that was a problem to be
solved yeah obviously
you know health care is always the last
frontier
to solve a problem right so
so i got involved in uh consulting with
uh the greater new york hospital
association on transitions of care and
and and things that nature started up uh
thompson's e-health media division here
in the u.s uh just prior to that and
then i got involved in a number of
different things as high-tech act took
off i got involved in a number of ehr
vendors uh and and helping them build
out specific uh solution portfolios so
tell me a little bit about you know the
telehealth and health tech space from
your from your perspective and your
career trajectory and sort of leading up
to you joining genie md
what's happening and
how did that all change when the cover
broke out
yeah that's a great question so think
about uh let's go back 10 years
in the high tech act right i talked
about paper in healthcare at the time
you know you when you walked into your
doctor's office your your health
information was on a paper wall
in a folder and a couple papers and you
got to look through you know there was
never it was not online and it was not
really accessible unless you were
physically had that folder in your hand
so high-tech took that paper off the
shelf put it and computerized it and now
here we are at covet
and what kovit did for unfortunately uh
kovit had
did exist
but what kovitt did with telehealth was
made
let me back uh we would not have been as
successful in treating patients during
covet
uh not necessarily in the emergency room
but uh but in the ambulatory centers
because
we would not have had access to the
um primary care office again they were
closed right so
high tech actually was a saving grace to
some degree
in having your information online right
and and then virtual care came along
before covet virtual care telehealth was
really a nice to have feature and it
really wasn't reimbursed well from the
uh from the payer side of the equation
and so therefore
uh covet went from a nice to have to a
must-have
uh feature within the delivery of care
model and then what we learned was hey
mikey liked it uh the doctors liked it
and the and the patients liked it and uh
and ultimately it they it started to
find uh its own way in the value
in which it brings to the delivery of
care model so bringing now healthcare
outside of the brick and mortar is now
seemed as very viable
uh and hence why and if it wasn't for
cms at the time that changed their
payment uh profile on what they would
cover during covet
uh it would not have had the success it
did have
so
uh
hats off to the cms team
at the time for making that happen
genie md
what is that
nene md uh the the uh the virtual care
is out of the bottle
with relative to
genius so uh but the point there being
is you know we provide a virtual care
platform we're actually we have two hats
that we wear on one side we are
integrated with the uh genie md medical
group so
you can uh and they provide urgent care
services online through a telehealth
session
uh so if you go to geniumd.com and click
on the link you you fill out your cheap
complaint and then eventually you might
see a doctor
uh that's one side of the equation
the flip side and when i say might see a
doctor is that uh you know you don't
necessarily have to have a
visual encounter with a patient between
a patient and doctor to get a
prescription written right so doctor
might say hey i understand your g
complaint got you got x y and z i just
sent a script over to your local farm
right
so on the on the flip side of that
equation uh gene emt provides a platform
so we talk about we might be in a
virtual care session right because it's
video but virtual care telehealth is
much more than just video
so what so what geniumd provides is a
full unified portfolio as i call it
that allows a patient and a provider to
engage in many different modalities
modalities meaning
asynchronously i can go on to my website
fill out a cheap complaint not ever see
you and then the doctor could respond in
many different ways he could respond
saying hey i get it as i just said or
hey let's schedule a call let's have a
conversation
and then it escalates to
you know something very new in the
market is and part of virtual care is
remote patient monitoring meaning you
have a chronic condition let's just say
you have um diabetes
and uh so as part of being
diagnosed as having being a person with
diabetes then uh we might provide you a
glucose monitor
might provide you maybe a blood pressure
cuff depending on the scenario and then
and then you get enrolled into these
programs and then we monitor you so
the the issue is that in in in the
classic model of delivery of care
let me just say the average medicare
patient as an example five chronic
conditions
five and sees nine different doctors in
a given year and they only have face
time with that doctor for 15 hours right
right so the question that we try to
answer and we leverage remote patient
monitoring is what happens the other
eight thousand seven hundred and forty
five hours right that's really where i
if and you know there's a big issue in
health care where you've gone through
the trouble of
scheduling for the doctor's visit you
are you know you got your diagnosis you
got your prescription but i never went
to the pharmacy to get it filled right
so the care plan and the behavioral
change necessary once you get a
diagnosis is very critical well that all
takes place in that
8745 hours right when you're at and what
not in front of the doctor right so
remote patient monitoring allows you to
have a device in your home
you take a measure 16 unique days out of
a given month
and then we monitor that data so if we
see that your
your glucose level is out of whack then
we can engage you
immediately if you will
and and and coach you
uh relative to what you need to do to
maintain a proper glucose level right
so
that's one of many different scenarios
where remote patient monitoring and on
top of that another
feature set within virtual care chronic
care management
is
is able to now provide a 24 7 care model
and but still leverage your provider
and still see them these 15 hours as i
as i've said we just provide now uh uh
coaching and monitoring services in
those other like i said that
8745 hours so now the delivery of care
models suddenly changes
right relative to
uh hopefully better outcomes which is
the intent less emergency room visits
because you you're not managing your
chronic condition properly and
potentially even less remittance so
we're lowering the cost of care while
increasing the quality of care right
that makes a lot of sense now as chief
growth officer you're obviously tasked
with the challenge of growth and you
know we can all agree that this is an
important
problem and the the solution may be
fantastic but how do you actually
position yourself to grow
you know especially at a time when this
is you know great momentum because
everybody's thinking about it
everybody's aware of it what is sort of
your strategic thinking around this
well uh covet was good and bad for for
the market right it was good because it
highlighted the value of telehealth and
it and it valued that there are
uh different ways of delivering care
outside of the brick and mortar and uh
we're still waiting on congress to
make them make all the changes they made
jordan covet uh permanent so that
because nothing happens in health care
unless it's funded right there's no you
know they're not it's not a charity case
in in in the context of uh everything is
uh for free but so the point there being
is if there's no
funding mechanism
reimbursement mechanism the providers
are less likely to engage in that
practice so
what we're doing is now defining what is
virtual care because as i've said
earlier
it's beyond telehealth it's beyond video
and
and so the that whole continuum of a
virtual care encounter inclusive of
remote patient monitoring
chronic care management
and there's a new category that cms
medicare medicaid is
launching in 22 relative to the remote
therapeutic monitoring meaning remote
patient monitoring says
you have to have a medical device to
report your data
therapeutic monitoring amongst other
things says i can
i can i can hand write up you i can type
in
my vitals right or other social economic
uh in
influences relative to the delivery of
care so so think about it telehealth
remote patient monitoring chronic care
management remote therapeutic monitoring
changes the whole dynamics so we're
trying to define
that
plot that
instance of virtual care
and the and it's all about the
differentiation our differentiation is
we support that continuum and it's not
about only technology but it's about the
programs and the services that sit on
top of the technology that ultimately
allows a provider who doesn't have time
anyway because they're seeing 25
patients a day and
they got their heads down in their ehr
how do they now monitor those patients
and engage those patients
genie md helps solve that problem do you
find that you that there is any consumer
behavior that needs to be explained or
shifted in order to make this the proper
growth is that is that a
part of the strategy that you're
thinking
it is a huge part of the strategy and
that's ultimately the the role of the
coach
uh because again uh there's too many
statistics and too many studies about
what happens after you leave the
doctor's office either
your you forget
what the doctor said no one wrote it
down or
you just don't go fill that script as i
said earlier
and
healthcare
is all about
behavioral change
just because you develop diabetes
doesn't mean you have to die with it
right and
right so
diet and exercise can go a long way
outside of taking the pill right
so how do you how do you
and it's hard
it trusts me it's hard
my father was a diabetic i get it uh and
uh and and if you don't have someone to
coach you outside of the doctor's office
it's very very tough
to achieve your
uh your goals if you're not willing to
if you don't have one encouraging you on
changing your behaviors
to achieve to as i say to move along
that awareness to wellness continuum the
awareness is your doctor just diagnosed
you with diabetes
the wellness is i've got it under
control and i've even got maybe even
gotten rid of it but what do you do in
the middle right behavioral changes in
the middle and and that's how you
progress towards a better a
better state of health i love it take me
back a little bit to your your journal
so you start off in your program you're
an engineer you move to networking and
wireless communication transition then
to you know to tell health a bunch of
different things you're obviously
extremely curious and lots of things
fascinate you but take me back to you
your childhood what really fascinated
you as a child what really sparked your
curiosity as a kid
oh man that's a tough one uh i was one
of six okay and we live and we lived in
a uh small house three-bedroom house
with eight people and one bathroom wow
um so uh and we weren't the uh the
wealthiest uh family on the block um uh
good or bad um one would say uh
good only because it it was a
uh
an eye-opener relative to
um you know
different ways of maybe doing it not
getting stuck in the in the fold of
thinking there's no way out right and uh
but there's always a way out you just
have to have a plan and you have to be
diligent about it so i was always uh on
the uh on the innovative front
thinking a bit differently uh
my mom always said that i uh i i uh i
ran to a different drum
uh and uh and uh you know just uh i just
was very diligent i didn't take
no was an answer i was uh very
persistent and uh i i might have done
things the hard way but it was
i uh i had a i had a i had
i had a dream if you will
uh that uh there was a better side of
life uh so um wow so that's that's a
little bit about my background and then
you obviously need a lot of inspiration
to have gone to the career that you've
gone through where do you gather your
inspiration today what what is something
or some things that inspire you today
uh it's just you know healthcare is just
a
you know it's the it's the two ends of a
spectrum right you have
the bad side of care because you know
there's a system out there that might
not be working as
best as it could
but then there's so much opportunity for
not to be in a system that focuses
on um
pain right i don't sometimes call it a
pain management system because
healthcare if it doesn't hurt you ain't
going to the doctor
right it's just
when you have pain you go to the doctor
and you're trying to figure out how do i
get rid of it right diabetes doesn't
hurt
right
and you might not even know you have but
i will tell you a story real quick
diabetes and my father had like i said
had it last five years one leg amputated
second leg amputated a third an arm
amputated and a couple fingers right so
it hurts in the end
uh it's just a matter of when you're
willing to accept
uh that you need to change your
behaviors and and find and find out your
consequences so uh it so
the ability to change a delivery of care
model
where you can be treated in the home
and um and to and but and still maximize
the ability to achieve wellness
and encourage people to think about diet
and exercise and and how it can change
uh how it can change them first but how
it can change their their family how it
can change their neighborhood
and how it can change frankly the world
and and because a healthier world
is is healthy for everybody
and what are two or three words that you
would use to describe yourself
uh persistent is the first word
uh the second word might be persistent
i i won't go as far to say the third
word is persistent but uh focus
uh
uh a focused persistency and uh and
knowledgeable i you gotta do your
homework uh and you gotta you know yeah
you're normal a hundred percent and i
can definitely say that you know like an
incredible journey incredible career and
just very very inspiring work
and i want to wish you best of luck with
junior md thank you for you know
improving the lives of so many people
around you
and thank you for inspiring me in these
20 minutes i really appreciate your time
and and this conversation
and stay safe and stay healthy and best
of luck with jeannie md
thanks for helping me uh having me and
same to you as well the best
you